what are more common in high dimensional  spaces  local minima or saddle points it's  tempting to think it's the local minima  because they are  often problematic in machine learning at  least in theory  however the right answer to this ai  coffee break quiz  is saddle points in a nutshell to tell  local minima apart from saddle points we  look at the hessian matrix which is  sort of the second derivative of a  function like the loss function  that takes as input a vector and outputs  a scalar for a local minimum the hessian  has only positive eigenvalues  for a saddle point it has a mixture of  positive  and negative eigenvalues now think about  it what is more likely to happen  to have exclusively n positive  eigenvalues in an n-dimensional space or  a mixture of both negative and positive  signs  well because a mix is more likely saddle  points are more likely to occur  they come with small gradients in their  vicinity making gradient-based  optimization  harder